hello hello welcome to an encounter
between anish giri
and magnus carlsen from the knockout
stage
their match from the quarterfinals and
the skilling open
this time you have anish with the white
pieces and the world champion
with the black so let's see how this
went down all right so we got
e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 the italian
opening bishop c5 from from magnus
castles knight f6 v3
so we have a duel in the italian this
opening is played so many times that i
guarantee you
in this very moment in the world there's
somebody playing in the italian
right now so d6 from
magnus c3 from from geary
h6 this move here is quite clever
um so first of all i should point out
that in the italian defense there
are a bunch of different move orders and
they
actually have a very significant
difference
with white for example you can play
knight bd2 rookie one
h3 at any point but it's a huge
difference if you play h3 before knight
bd2
and whether or not you play a4 and
there's a lot of
things that seem to be very small but
they actually matter
a great deal and that is the case of h6
as well
because if i do castle which is another
main move
we do allow the option of bishop g5 and
this
is kind of unpleasant it's it's a huge
line a completely different story where
the line often goes like this
where black at some point can play g5 in
the position becomes very
very complicated so even here it could
be
possible to take on g5 just to mention
that that there are a lot of different
ways to play these
positions but i like h6 it does prevent
bishop g5
and i think it's a good way to go so
knight bd2 from uh
geary the classic way to continue let me
also say that a4 here is another
critical move
and i can also say that after h3 g5
is not so dumb to try to play g4 because
that is the problem when you play
when to play h3 is that now black can
open up the position with
g4 and look look at black's king yeah
it's not castled yet which means that g4
is certainly uh possible and black
can either keep his king in the center
or castle queenside
but knight bd2 from uh geary castles uh
from magnus rookie one once again it's
possible to play a4
a4 a5 this is a typical way to continue
rookie one and magnus plays a5 anyway
this move has become
quite popular recently i played it a
bunch
uh myself i think dean lee wren was the
one
who made it popular in the first place
and the point is that sometimes black
can play a4
while also he prevents white from
playing b form
the only downside is that now what black
is played a5
he loses control of the b5 squares so
white can continue with a4
and then have a nice grip on that square
knight f1 from geary bishop b6 bishop b5
this is all theory and here there are a
lot of moves
a lot of different ways to play i think
bishop b6 is one of
one option and the other option at
magnus plays knight e7
uh let me quickly show you another
difference between playing knight f1 and
simply h3 here
because if you play h3 bishop e6 bishop
e5
you notice that this position is almost
the same
but there is a huge difference in this
position queen b8
is one of the main moves just to put the
queen on a7
in this diagonal and attack the f2 pawn
and the huge huge difference here is
that d4
is not possible because the knight
stands in the way
but now that white has played knight f1
d4
is a possible move which means that the
idea of queen b8 wouldn't be that good
because of d4 so bishop b6 bishop d5
knight e7 d4 geary takes his chance to
strike in the center this is also theory
bishop a7 from magnus
i'm not sure if this is the main move
i do remember that i've seen something
like this before
but it certainly could be in another
position
but i'm sure i've seen this position
before played in a bunch of games
i mean every move has been tried because
these positions are played
as i did mention earlier all the time
d4 bishop a7 takes on e5 magnus simply
plays knight g4 he's sacrificing a pawn
but now he is
aiming at f2 here e represents that with
bishop e3
takes on e3 takes on e3 and this
is indeed upon sacrifice from the world
champion
very interesting uh there's certainly
also a possibility of taking there but
that would allow white to take on a7
rook takes and then simply
knight d4 and the rook on a7 here is
quite awkward
it is so awkward that i think that white
has a very good position perhaps even
clearly better because he's gonna go f4
next and uh
he's gonna get a nice nice grip in the
center
so knight takes e3 makes uh sense knight
takes c3
d takes e5 and gear takes the pawn with
knight takes c5 delicious stuff
knight g6 from the world champion he's
hoping that his two
bishops gives him enough gives him
enough compensation
for the missing pawn and
he is quite right in his judgment he has
a nice compound compensation
let's see what happens uh next uh
knight takes g6 i can quickly mention
that it would have been better to simply
take on d8 and after
rook takes d8 simply knight f3 with the
idea of controlling d2 this is quite
important
and and another thing is that
if he does not if he for example takes
in g6 here
takes back it's not so easy to prevent
rook d2
in a in a nice way because you can never
play rook d1 because the a2 pawn will be
hanging
and if you play rook ed1 then black can
take on e3
so knight takes g6 after f takes g6
rook queen takes d8 rook takes yet we
actually get the same position we
just analyzed more or less and uh
the issue here is as i said it's not so
easy to prevent
rook d2 and that is a little bit
unpleasant and the way
geary does it is that he plays e2 it is
the logical way to prevent it
magnus takes on e3 and nigiri now takes
with the f
pawn and already black is
actually doing quite well and it's it
looks quite strange
rather curious i must add that
that black is a palm down but he is
in a better he has a better position
incredibly enough and that's primarily
because of these pawns here are
they're pretty bad they're weak so the
extra pawn doesn't
add much and not only that black has
excellent coordination here between the
pieces and white stroke on e2 is
very awkward the rook on a1 is also
quite bad
which means that geary has gotten
himself a worse position
it would have been better to say oh man
i
queen takes d8 knight takes g6 first
wasn't that great
so i should just take with the rook and
allow rook d2
and after brook e2 and rook fta
the position is uh certainly going to
turn into a draw after for example king
f1
rook d1 rookie one and then rookie two
uh repetition is uh
forced and a draw is a decent result
for uh for magnus and for gary too i
suppose
but he did not take with the rook it
took with the f pawn
and magnus plays kf7 so improves his
king's position
he's just going to put the king on e7
and it's quite difficult to find
uh decent moves there for for white so
we replace bishop
a4 he wants to put the bishop on on b3
in the future maybe even bishop c2 and
maybe also play rook d1 to trade off a
pair of rooks
king a7 simple chess from magnus he
improves his king's position
h3 from um
from geary bishop um
bishop c4 attacking uh the rook and
already
giri is in huge problems
he has gotten himself in a clearly worse
position and he needs to fight
hard in order to save this and magnus is
the last opponent you want in a position
like this
like if you give him an inch he is going
to take
take a mile so rook c2
is the only move rook d3
you can now see how weak these pawns are
and if you
lose one of them you are bound to lose
the other one as well
and we also see that gary has problems
with his bishop
so rook e1 king d6
and it's looking better and better for
magnus carson
right now in this position one thing
that's quite annoying
is that you cannot play rook f2 for
example
because rook takes king takes and then
rook d2 and everything is going to fall
here on the queen side
which is kind of a it's a kind of huge
problem you do not have a lot of moves
here
so gear replace the logical bishop e3
black does not want to let white trade a
bishop so it goes to a6
rook c1 rook d1 is going to come next
king e5
the king is placed on an excellent
square on e5 right in the middle of the
board
rook d1 geary needs to to trade off
pieces the more pieces you trade off the
closer you are to a
draw so rook d3 rook d1 makes a lot of
sense
rook d8 rook takes d3
and bishop takes d3 in here gary has
gotten himself
in a very very tough end game the pawn
on e4
is going to fall the pawn on e3 is very
weak
and black has the more active rook as
well so
everything is looking good for magnus
right here and
um in this position i can mention
quickly that rook
f1 would have been a better move the
point of rook f1 is that you want to
take on d3
and then play f7 to start a counter
attack here and that's one of the things
you should try to do
when you are in a worse position you
should try to attack and go for a
counter attack
because it's much harder to to attack
when you get attacked simultaneously
than than attack when your opponent is
playing
passively so if you play actively the
chances of you holding the game
increases so rook f1 would have been a
better try
because after rook takes d3 bishop takes
d3 and there's no rook f1
that is a huge problem and there's no d1
either because i can simply play rook d6
and there's no pin this rook is
not doing too well here
king f2 from geary tries to get his king
in
onto the board but this pawn on e3 is
ruining stuff for him if it could have
played quick king e3 at some point
or let's say he just had his pawn at f3
it would have been much much much better
but king f2 rook d6 bishop d1
he needs to get his bishop on an active
square
so he wants to put it on f3 bishop c4
from magnus an excellent move b3 attacks
the bishops but now
the bishop sorry but now rook d2
and the rook is officially in geary's
position here attacking the pawn on a2
king g3 and the bishop e6 the pawn on a2
is in huge trouble here so kieran needs
to move it but he doesn't move it
because it doesn't really matter if he
moves it or not
if he would have played a4 something
like rook b2 is very good
and then bishop takes b3 comes next with
a
devastating effect and everything is
going to fall here
every pawn and black's pawns are just
running up the border here
so rook if one from geary rook takes a2
from
from magnus bishop g4
takes b3 magnus has now won two pawns
look at all of these pawns they are just
uh weak
rook f8 from geary king takes e4
magnus is now up two pawns rook c8
king takes e3 rook takes c7 but
unfortunately for geary
these two pawns here are far far too
strong
so magnus plays bishop d5 is now
attacking g2
so that must be defended take sex
and rook b2 rook takes g7
the very simple way here is to defend
the g6 pawn to avoid no counter play
so magnus plays rook b6 and after c4
king d4 rook c7 protecting the pawn on
c4
but magnus can now start running his a
pawn up the border here with uh
with a4 c5 rook a6
the rook is now behind the past pawn the
best placement the rook can have is
behind the the past pawn
rook takes p7 king takes c5
rook c7 king b6 rook c1
magnus can simply start running with a3
so he's going to play a2
and then he's going to run the king up
the board and it's
going to be very hard for gary to save
this game he's tries with h4
a2 rk1 rook a4 magnus doesn't want to
allow any counter play
so for example if king c5 is played i
guess magnus
doesn't want any stuff like h5 takes
king h4 to be possible and in
in the future sacrifice this rook
and then all of a sudden survive but
i guess he just wanted to be on the safe
side he has
excellent control here with the rook so
this as well would have been
completely winning but he played okay
for to even
to prevent that as well the slightest
chance of counter play
f4 h5 he plays h5 he doesn't want to
allow h5 followed by f5
king f3 kc5 king e3
king d5 king f3 and king e6
and his plan is simple is going to play
king f5 he's going to play rook a3 and
then he will win the pawn on f4
he's going to win the pawn on h4 and
the g pawn or nh pawns will
will run down the board and the game is
over so this was an excellent excellent
game by
magnus carson this is him at his very
very best
as we say in a region and i did say they
use the same expression in english
when you give her the finger she takes
the whole hand
when you give her a finger then she
takes the whole end
and that is certainly true with magnus
when you play chess
the slightest chance was uh
after f takes e3 the position is
certainly unpleasant it's of course
far from lost but it's very unpleasant
and as i did say magnus carlsen is the
last
very last opponent you want to to face
in a position like this
it's out of nowhere you you actually
have to fight for a draw
and then he just improves his pieces
like he accidentally did here
and already at this point like king e5
i think the position is close to being
objectively lost
and as i did say giris's last chance
would have been to play
rook f1 with the point of that rook
takes d1 as more or less forced
and this end game here is uh not so
clear
and certainly possible to hold but
afterwards
it becomes too difficult to hold this
end game
is lost and magnus is one in
in the spectacular magnus style
so hats off to him and
i am excited for
[Music]
for what tomorrow will bring stay tuned
for more